ladies and Gentlemen let's take one
quick look how we got here
who's winning the fight at you and
Samuel
Samuel and I wondered if you'd be paid
to put your money where your mouth is
you've called me out for a fight you
know I accept you take the 50 Grand bet
yeah well he won't be able so you want
to fight and talk already yeah
you wait man you wait do you fancy your
chances against it I've won the fight
already yeah I'm training [__] hard
walks and talks and is and you can see
that he is a wimp the fact that you tell
me I look [__] means I know I look good
I actually feel bad for the guy because
this is delusional he's like in his 40s
he's really skinny I'm very worried for
him because I will be going full force
and knocking him out I mean he might
even Lube himself up in the ring
that's how slippery the guy is oh my
predictions I'm gonna knock him out
everything is I'm bigger than him I'm
stronger than him it's not really a fair
comparison I just got called out and I
just thought you're a mouthy Twan I'm
gonna love winning that fight he's gonna
wish he hadn't gotten in that ring with
me
raise the roof for rock more
his opponents standing across the ring
fighting out of the Red Corner give it
up for Samuel Lee
[Applause]
if she ain't [__] she got to go tell
her don't waste my time police want to
stop me search my clothes
my phone
tell him or waste my time
[Music]
tell them don't waste my time oh yeah
tell him don't waste my time
[Music]
tell them don't waste my time
[Applause]
[Music]
pray to the Lord [__] in this cold
world
this fight is scheduled for free two
minute rounds two hundred thousand
pounds when it's EXO Let's Get It On
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
seconds out round two
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
you check us out third and final round
all right
[Applause]
foreign
okay ladies and gentlemen
first of all I have welcomed the owner
of the main sponsor of this event we
fund your trade it will present the
winner with the WCB events prestigious
Championship belt
the scorecards are in
and the winner by majority decision
in the Red Corner Samuel
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen give it up for your
winner
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen let's hear from
your winner
Samuel
we have been building this fight for
months
going backwards forwards multiple press
conferences
you said what you was going to do how
are you feeling buddy
I feel amazing I'm in the best shape of
my life and I just want to say a massive
thank you to every single person that
can Matt supported me tonight
foreign
big respect
because it's because because not many
people would get in the ring and he got
in the ring so I have to say respect I
trained very hard for this fight as you
can see my body's transformed I was a
different man to the man that Rob agreed
to fight but uh I've always been
underestimated in business everyone
always says I'm a talker I'm not a doer
I think this proves I ain't a talker I'm
a doer
um
and also as well
sometimes being Progressive just doesn't
work you've got to go to fight camp
[Applause]
Samuel you came here you said what you
was going to do you got the victory
congratulations
[Applause]
ladies and Gentlemen let's hear from Rob
Moore please give and the absolute who's
here for this man for stepping in the
ring
[Applause]
foreign
what an atmosphere this has been it's
been an absolute pleasure to host this
for you just tell me how you're feeling
right now buddy
I'm disappointed I lost but
um I had a good opponent who brought it
and most people would step in this ring
and he did
um this event goes to Steph a beloved
person in our company who passed away
um
and
we
we raised nearly four of a million
pounds of Charity I'm just a bit pissed
off it came out of my pocket
nearly a quarter of a million pound to
charity from one of them that's
absolutely incredible big props for both
of these guys I'm Darren turns it from
WCB events thank you for making this
night so special have a safe journey
home go and party and we'll see you all
again soon foreign
[Music]
oh